SPEAKER 1: In the
past few videos,
we've talked about how
different recommenders can
help with cost, performance, and
security in your Google Cloud
projects.
For enterprises and
larger organizations,
it's likely that you'll
have many projects.
In order to take full
advantage of the benefits
from recommendations,
you might need
to scale how you handle them
such as incorporating them
into a pipeline to
programmatically manage them.
Today, let's go over some tips
for how an enterprise could
leverage
recommendations at scale
and show you how to export your
recommendations to BigQuery so
that they can be reviewed
across your organization.
The benefits of Active Assist
were great even if you only
have one project.
But they really begin to shine
in an organization with lots
of projects.
In each project,
various recommenders
will help you apply the
principle of least privilege
for security, minimize
resource waste from workloads,
and maximize the performance of
business critical applications.
Because of the increased
scale of operations
in a large organization,
you'll want to review and take
action on recommendations with
minimal administrative work
in time.
What this looks like
for your organization
will be unique to your
workloads, infrastructure,
security, and processes.
While the exact details depend
on what works best for you,
we recommend a three
phased approach
for adopting
recommenders at scale.
As you move through these
phases at your own pace,
the potential for
automation increases.
Let's start with the
first phase-- accessing
recommendations through
the recommendation hub
in the Google Cloud console.
The recommendation hub
is the simplest way
of accessing and
managing recommendations
in your projects
and organization.
Reviewing recommendations
in the recommendation hub
will familiarize you with
different recommenders
available so that you can
think about how you might
like to prioritize
them when building
a pipeline in a later phase.
Working from the
console also includes
being able to set
up a BigQuery data
transfer to export your
recommendations to a BigQuery
data set.
When you do this,
two tables will
be generated--
recommender-export,
where the recommendations
are exported;
and insight-export,
where the insights that
help you focus on important
patterns are exported.
Insights can provide additional
context to recommendations,
or they can be
used independently.
By exporting
recommendations to BigQuery,
you're able to look at
details for project level
recommendations across
your organization.
With that ability, you can
expand by creating dashboards
to help you visualize and
report the potential impact
of applying recommendations.
Once you're familiarized
with the console
and with the data
exported to BigQuery,
the next phase of recommenders
at scale is to use the APIs.
All of the recommendation
data that you
can access to the Recommender
hub or the BigQuery export
is also available via an API.
The recommendation resource
returned by the API
will include lots of information
about a single recommendation
including the priority,
the expected impact,
and the status of the
recommendation such as active
or dismissed.
You can also use an
API to return insights.
Just like in the
BigQuery exports,
insights can provide
additional context
for associated recommendations.
For example, a recommendation
from the IAM policy recommender
to reduce the
permissions for a user
may have an associated
insight that
includes the permissions that
have been used in the past 90
days, and therefore
should not be removed.
You can use the API to view
recommendations and insights
as well as to update
their status if you
choose to take action on them.
When getting started
with the API,
you'll probably want to
require manual review.
But you can start
introducing automation
to help scale and handle
more recommendations.
This can also help
lay the foundation
for the third phase--
integrating recommendations
into your organization's DevOps
pipelines.
If your organization has
a well-established DevOps
strategy, changes to
your Cloud Infrastructure
might be managed through
continuous integration
and continuous
deployment processes.
The goal for scaling
recommendations
should be to automate
the review, analysis,
and implementation.
For example, you
could set up Cloud Run
to regularly retrieve
recommendations via the API
and then automatically
generate a pull request
in your infrastructure as code
repository for that recommended
change.
That pull request
can be reviewed
by an administrative team.
And if accepted merged,
the included recommendation
can move on in the
pipeline and subsequently
be applied to your
Cloud infrastructure.
By incorporating recommendations
in your CI/CD pipeline,
you can proactively
monitor recommendations.
Applied changes that are
kept consistent in code
can easily be reviewed,
tested, and rolled back
using the same processes
used for the rest
of your infrastructure.
This level of automation
and integration
is ideal for large
organizations and enterprises.
But no matter what scale
you're working with,
you can still always take
advantage of recommendations.
It can also be helpful to
start slow and take the time
to get familiar
with recommendations
and how they impact your Cloud
infrastructure before you
implement a full blown
automation process.
We've taken a look at the
recommendation hub before.
So now let's take
a look at how we
can get those recommendations
into BigQuery.
You can do this by
setting up a BigQuery data
transfer with the
recommendations as the source.
To do that, you'll need to have
the recommendations exporter
role assigned on your
organization's IAM policy.
This will give you access to the
organization's recommendations
across projects.
Start in the recommendation hub
where you can find the Export
button at the top of the page.
The first step is to provide
the destination project
where the recommendation
data will be stored.
The destination project
can be any project
that you have access to.
But you'll need to have
the following permissions
for that project--
bigquery.datasets.create,
bigquery.transfers.get,
bigquery.transfers.update,
resourcemanager.projects.update,
serviceusage.services.enable,
and serviceusage.services.get.
In addition, the BigQuery
API and BigQuery transfer API
will need to be enabled
for that project.
The next step is to
configure the transfer
with a few details
like name, schedule,
and a target BigQuery data set.
When it comes to
choosing a schedule,
you'll have the option of
daily, weekly, monthly,
or your own custom schedule.
You'll also be able to configure
notifications via email
if the transfer fails or
publish to a Pub/Sub topic
when a transfer completes.
Once complete, you'll be
able to see your new BigQuery
data transfer details
in the console.
And it should begin populating
data within about two days.
Once the transfer has
had a chance to run,
you'll see those two
tables we mentioned earlier
in your selected
BigQuery data set--
recommendation_export
and insight_export.
We'll include a link
to the documentation
where you can see the
full table schema.
Recommendations will also have
a field for associated insights
so you can look up any insight
details in the insight exports
table.
With recommendation data
exported to BigQuery,
you'll be able to
write custom queries
to analyze recommendations.
From there, you can
expand by exporting
to Data Studio or
Google Sheets, where
you can further analyze for
patterns and opportunities
to optimize.
You can also begin to automate
by accessing that Recommender
API and follow that up by
including recommendations
into programmatic
processes as part
of your established
CI/CD pipelines.
Recommendations are available
for all Google Cloud users.
If your organization
has a support package,
you'll also have access to the
full API and BigQuery export.
We'll include a link
in the description
with more information.
We'll also include some
links in the description
if you'd like to find
even more information
and guidance on using
active assistant scale.
And remember, the right solution
depends on your organization
and what makes sense for you.
Don't be afraid to
implement these over time
instead of jumping
immediately to the most
complicated solution.
Stay tuned for more videos.
And thanks for watching.